Nous avons tous besoin de pouvoir communiquer des informations privées sans craindre d'être espionnés. Mais concevoir un
système infaillible pour cela n'est pas simple. Dans cet épisode de Qiskit in the Classroom, nous allons parler de comment
quelque chose appelé la distribution quantique de clés peut
aider. Bienvenue dans Qiskit in the Classroom. Dans cette série, nous abordons des sujets que tu pourrais rencontrer dans un cours
universitaire lié à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif dont le lien se trouve dans la description,
alors assure-toi de le consulter. Aujourd'hui, nous allons explorer le domaine de la cryptographie quantique. La cryptographie est l'étude
des techniques de communication sécurisée. C'est incroyablement important pour de nombreux aspects de nos vies. Chaque fois que tu utilises un
mot de passe pour te connecter à un site web, envoies un paiement numérique, ou lorsque les gouvernements transmettent des renseignements militaires, tout cela se fait
à travers un protocole cryptographique pour qu'un espion ne puisse pas apprendre nos secrets. Mais il y a une tension ici. Comment
s'assurer que la personne avec qui l'on veut communiquer peut comprendre notre message, mais que personne d'autre ne le peut ?
Historiquement, les cryptographes ont inventé de nombreux protocoles différents pour essayer de rendre leurs messages aussi imperméables
que possible aux espions. Parfois, les deux parties qui veulent communiquer de façon sécurisée se mettent d'accord sur un certain
code au préalable, qui est suffisamment compliqué pour qu'un espion ne puisse pas le déchiffrer. Mais comme
des gens comme Alan Turing et d'autres casseurs de codes en temps de guerre nous l'ont montré, même les codes les plus compliqués peuvent être
déchiffrés. Idéalement, on aimerait envoyer des messages chiffrés de telle façon qu'il n'y ait absolument aucun schéma
et aucun moyen pour un espion de comprendre sans posséder également une clé aléatoire secrète que seuls l'expéditeur et le
destinataire connaissent. Mais cela nous expose à une nouvelle vulnérabilité. Comment envoyer cette clé en étant sûr que
personne ne l'intercepte ? En 1984, Charles Bennett et Jill Brassard ont trouvé une
méthode pour envoyer une clé de façon sécurisée avec des bits quantiques, qui s'appelle maintenant BB84. La caractéristique clé de ces
bits quantiques ou qubits qui permet ce protocole est qu'ils obéissent au principe d'incertitude. Tu ne peux pas mesurer
un système quantique sans le perturber. Aujourd'hui, on va commencer par un exemple de code cryptographique simple. Ensuite, je vais
te montrer comment la distribution quantique de clés et le principe d'incertitude peuvent nous permettre d'utiliser des chiffrements quasi incassables.
Je vais t'expliquer le protocole BB84 en détail, et enfin nous allons l'exécuter sur un vrai ordinateur quantique.
Commençons par un jeu que tu as peut-être déjà vu, appelé un cryptogramme.
On te donne une séquence de lettres apparemment aléatoires, mais en utilisant ta connaissance des schémas de la langue anglaise,
tu peux substituer une lettre à une autre pour donner un sens au message. Voici un exemple. Il s'agit d'un
message secret avec un simple chiffrement par substitution. Ainsi, tous les R représentent une lettre, les M représentent
une autre, et ainsi de suite. Si tu veux essayer de le résoudre toi-même, mets la vidéo en pause maintenant.
Il s'avère que ce message a été chiffré à l'aide d'un chiffrement très simple appelé le chiffrement de César, où
l'alphabet est simplement décalé d'un certain nombre — dans ce cas 9. Donc A devient J, B
devient K, C devient L, et ainsi de suite. Plus le message est long, plus il est facile de
voir le schéma. Donc avec un message aussi long que celui qu'on nous donne, le chiffrement de César ou tout autre chiffrement qui
substitue simplement une lettre de l'alphabet à une autre est assez simple à déchiffrer. Une façon plus sécurisée de coder un message secret
est avec ce qu'on appelle un masque à usage unique. Avec un masque à usage unique, tu peux avoir un décalage différent pour chaque lettre du
message. Il te suffit d'indiquer à ton ami le décalage appliqué à chacune pour qu'il puisse décoder le message.
Cette liste de décalages s'appelle la clé ou le masque. On l'appelle masque à usage unique car il est utilisé une fois puis jeté.
S'il est utilisé plus d'une fois, des schémas émergent qui pourraient rendre le chiffrement déchiffrable. Avec le chiffrement
par masque à usage unique, le message chiffré et la clé, pris individuellement, sont juste une chaîne aléatoire de nonsense. Mais
quand tu les combines, tu vois un message secret émerger du bruit.
Faisons un bref exemple. Disons que j'ai déjà créé et envoyé à mon ami ce masque à usage unique, qui est généralement écrit en
binaire. Et ensuite je veux envoyer le message « I love quantum ». Alors j'encoderais le message
avec le masque à usage unique comme ceci. On convertit d'abord les lettres du message en binaire. Chaque lettre de A à Z
correspond aux nombres 1 à 26 écrits en binaire. Donc A sera 0 0
0 1, B sera 0 0 1
0, C sera 0 0 1 1, et ainsi
de suite. Et un espace sera juste des zéros.
Voici alors ce que devient le message. On encode le message en effectuant un XOR entre chaque bit du message et
le bit correspondant dans le masque à usage unique. Si tu n'as jamais vu XOR auparavant,
c'est l'abréviation de « ou exclusif ». Le XOR entre deux bits vaut un si seulement l'un
des bits est un, et zéro si les deux sont zéro ou les deux sont un. Donc les cinq premiers bits du message encodé
deviennent 1 0
0 1 1. Je te laisse faire le reste des XOR toi-même. Mais le point essentiel est
que ce message est maintenant juste une chaîne aléatoire de zéros et de uns sans aucun schéma. Il est complètement indéchiffrable par quiconque
ne possède pas le masque à usage unique qu'on a utilisé pour chiffrer le message. Alors, qu'avons-nous appris jusqu'ici ? Certains schémas de chiffrement
sont meilleurs que d'autres, et certains peuvent être déduits par une personne intelligente qui recherche des schémas dans le message chiffré.
Mais une clé véritablement aléatoire qui décale chaque lettre d'un message secret d'un montant aléatoire différent ne peut pas être
déduite car il n'y a aucun schéma dans le message. La seule vulnérabilité dans un tel schéma est de s'assurer
que la clé utilisée pour chiffrer le message ne tombe pas entre de mauvaises mains. C'est là qu'intervient la distribution quantique de clés.
En utilisant des qubits, Bennett et Brassard ont trouvé un moyen pour deux parties de se mettre d'accord sur une clé en étant
raisonnablement sûrs qu'une tierce partie n'écoutait pas secrètement. Ce protocole BB84 est un peu compliqué, mais
nous allons l'expliquer étape par étape. Pour cette explication, faisons revenir nos vieux amis Alice et
Bob. Le protocole commence par Alice qui prépare un ensemble de qubits à envoyer à Bob. Ces qubits contiennent les
informations qui deviendront leur masque à usage unique partagé ou clé. Alice génère d'abord deux séquences aléatoires de
même longueur. L'une est une séquence aléatoire de zéros et de uns, et l'autre est une séquence aléatoire de X et de Z représentant la
base dans laquelle elle va préparer ses qubits. Ensuite, elle va préparer chaque qubit dans un état quantique selon la
combinaison de la base et de la valeur du bit indiquée dans ce tableau. Donc si le bit est zéro et la base est z, elle va
préparer le qubit dans l'état zéro. Ou si le bit est un et la base est X, elle le préparera dans l'état moins. Si
tu n'es pas sûr de ce que sont ces bases et états quantiques, ce n'est pas grave. L'essentiel que tu dois savoir est que
les mesures dans chaque base n'ont que deux résultats possibles : 0 ou 1 pour la base Z, et plus ou moins pour la base X.
Si tu mesures l'état zéro dans la base Z, tu obtiendras toujours zéro.
Mais si tu mesures ce même état dans la base x, tu obtiendras un résultat aléatoire, soit plus soit moins, chacun avec 50 %
de chance. Donc Alice pourrait préparer une chaîne de qubits comme ceci, où voici la chaîne aléatoire de
zéros et de uns, et voici la chaîne aléatoire de X et de Z. Donc le premier élément de chacune de ses
deux séquences était 0 et x. Cela signifie qu'elle va préparer le premier qubit dans l'état plus, et ainsi
de suite. Une fois qu'elle a préparé tous ses états de qubits, Alice va envoyer ces qubits à Bob, et Bob va choisir aléatoirement entre X
et Z comme base dans laquelle mesurer chacun d'eux. On ajoute donc quelques lignes au
tableau pour représenter les choix et mesures de Bob. Voici donc les
mesures et choix de base de Bob. Et voici ses résultats de mesure des qubits qu'Alice lui a envoyés. Enfin, Bob
peut convertir chaque mesure en un bit en utilisant le même tableau qu'Alice a utilisé pour préparer ses qubits. Quand il mesure l'état
zéro ou l'état plus, il assigne la valeur de bit zéro. Et là où il mesure l'état un ou l'état moins, il met
un. La chaîne de bits finale de Bob est donc cette dernière ligne.
Remarque que lorsque les bases de l'étape de préparation d'Alice et de l'étape de mesure de Bob correspondent, leurs bits correspondent aussi.
Mais si Alice choisit de préparer en Z et que Bob mesure en X, ou vice versa,
alors les bits correspondants d'Alice et Bob ne seront pas nécessairement les mêmes. Donc une façon pour eux de se mettre d'accord sur une chaîne de bits
pour leur masque à usage unique est de s'appeler et de se dire quelles bases ils ont utilisées pour chaque qubit.
Quand les bases correspondent, ils gardent le bit, et quand elles ne correspondent pas, ils le jettent.
Ainsi, dans ce cas, Alice et Bob se mettront tous les deux d'accord sur une chaîne de bits de 0 0 1 0
0. Comment ce schéma protège-t-il contre des espions non détectés ? Voyons ce qui se passe quand un tel espion
nommé Eve intercepte les qubits qu'Alice envoie à Bob. Elle ne sait pas dans quel état ces qubits se trouvent ni comment
Alice les a préparés. Donc, grâce au principe d'incertitude et à quelque chose appelé le théorème de non-clonage, elle ne peut pas
juste faire une copie identique des qubits à transmettre à Bob. Si elle le pouvait, elle serait en mesure d'espionner
sans être détectée. Au lieu de cela, elle devine une base dans laquelle mesurer chaque qubit, les mesure, puis
prépare un nouvel ensemble de qubits falsifiés à envoyer à Bob. Il y a d'autres façons plus subtiles qu'Eve pourrait essayer pour
se renseigner sur les qubits, mais aucune ne contourne le principe d'incertitude.
Donc, on va simplement supposer cette méthode directe d'espionnage d'Eve. Voici un tableau décrivant
la préparation d'Alice, l'interception d'Eve et la mesure finale de Bob. Donc maintenant quand
Alice et Bob se parlent au téléphone pour comparer leurs bases, ils décideront de garder ces bits pour leur clé, mais les
bits ne correspondent pas. C'est parce que Bob mesurait des qubits préparés par Eve, pas les qubits originaux qu'Alice avait.
S'ils comparent un sous-ensemble des bits de leurs chaînes de bits entre eux, ils verront que certains ne correspondent pas et
en déduiront qu'il devait y avoir un espion. Comme Eve a été découverte, Alice et Bob vont jeter
leurs chaînes de bits et recommencer le protocole depuis le début. Mais si Eve n'avait pas écouté et que le sous-ensemble de
bits qu'Alice et Bob ont comparés correspondait, alors ils pourraient aller de l'avant et utiliser les bits restants qu'ils n'ont pas
comparés comme clé partagée. Une fois qu'Alice et Bob ont une clé partagée, Alice peut envoyer des messages chiffrés à Bob, et
Bob est le seul à pouvoir les déchiffrer à l'aide de la clé. Maintenant qu'on a parcouru le protocole, essayons-le sur un
ordinateur quantique. Il y a quelques points à garder à l'esprit pour cette expérience. Premièrement,
BB84 n'est vraiment utile que si Alice et Bob sont loin l'un de l'autre. Pour l'expérience qu'on va faire, Alice
et Bob sont sur la même puce quantique. Donc cette expérience ne sera pas utile pour échanger des informations privées, mais c'est
quand même une bonne démonstration conceptuelle de BB84.
Deuxièmement, les vrais ordinateurs quantiques ont du bruit. Donc même si la base de préparation d'Alice correspond à la base de mesure de Bob
et qu'il n'y avait pas d'espion, il y a toujours une petite chance qu'ils mesurent des bits différents à cause d'erreurs dans
l'ordinateur quantique. Quand ils comparent leurs chaînes de bits pour vérifier la présence d'espions, ils doivent avoir une certaine tolérance pour les erreurs avant de
conclure qu'un espion a dû les manipuler et de jeter toute la clé. Avec ces
mises en garde, commençons par une expérience sans espion. D'abord, on génère aléatoirement
trois chaînes de bits différentes, chacune avec 20 bits. La première est la chaîne de bits initiale d'Alice.
La deuxième est une liste de bases dans lesquelles Alice va préparer ses qubits.
Ici, on a choisi zéro pour représenter la base Z et un pour représenter la base X. La dernière liste est les bases dans
lesquelles Bob va mesurer chaque qubit. À partir de ces trois listes, on peut faire un circuit diagram avec des instructions pour
la préparation d'Alice et les mesures de Bob. Tous les qubits commencent dans l'état zéro. Donc pour préparer ses qubits dans
la base Z, Alice ne fait rien pour l'état zéro, ou applique une porte NOT ou X indiquée par les boîtes bleues étiquetées X
pour l'état un. Pour préparer dans la base X, elle applique soit une porte Hadamard qui transforme zéro en l'état plus
ou une porte NOT suivie d'une porte Hadamard pour préparer l'état moins. Ensuite, elle envoie les qubits à Bob. L'ensemble de boîtes suivant
dans le circuit représente les mesures de Bob. Pour mesurer dans la base Z, il n'a pas besoin d'appliquer d'autres gates.
Il mesure juste, ce qui est représenté par ces boîtes grises. Pour mesurer dans la base X, il applique d'abord une porte Hadamard
puis il mesure. On va exécuter ce circuit en utilisant le primitif sampler de Qiskit runtime. Et la sortie est la chaîne de bits
de mesures de Bob. On peut ensuite comparer la chaîne de bits de Bob avec la chaîne de bits initiale d'Alice en éliminant les bits
où leurs bases ne correspondaient pas. Et on voit qu'ils obtiennent tous les deux la même clé.
Rappelle-toi qu'il s'agit de vrai matériel, donc il peut arriver qu'un bit devrait correspondre mais ne correspond pas. Dans ce cas, tous les
bits correspondent, mais si tu refais cette expérience toi-même, tu pourrais obtenir une erreur, mais tant que la fidélité est proche de un,
Alice et Bob peuvent être raisonnablement sûrs qu'il n'y avait pas d'espion. Voyons maintenant ce qui se passe si Eve intercepte les
qubits. On a maintenant deux circuits. Le premier montre la préparation d'Alice et l'interception et la
mesure d'Eve. Le suivant montre la préparation des qubits falsifiés par Eve et la mesure de Bob. On
peut exécuter ces circuits comme avant, puis voir ce qu'Alice et Bob obtiendraient quand ils comparent leurs chaînes de
bits. Cette fois, ils obtiennent une fidélité de 0,6 périodique. C'est bien inférieur à ce qui
peut s'expliquer par le bruit de l'ordinateur quantique. Ils concluent donc qu'Eve espionnait. L'informatique quantique est
bien connue et souvent vantée pour son potentiel à résoudre des problèmes difficiles. Mais la communication et la cryptographie quantiques
reçoivent souvent beaucoup moins d'attention, même si le potentiel que le quantique peut offrir dans ces domaines est tout aussi
important et passionnant. Aujourd'hui, nous avons discuté du premier protocole découvert pour la distribution quantique de clés, qui est
pratiquement immunisé contre l'espionnage non détecté. Si tu veux essayer d'envoyer un code incassable avec
une clé certifiée quantiquement, rends-toi sur le module dont le lien se trouve dans la description.
Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine fois.